may 11 1960 seemed like a completely
normal day for ricardo clements he lived
in argentina and spent most of his day
at his job working for mercedes-benz in
bruno's iris as was his usual routine
ricardo got on a bus every evening eager
to get back to his wife and kids
unfortunately that day he missed his
usual bus and was an hour and a half
late in a hurry he started walking home
on the sidewalk
suddenly a man appeared out of nowhere
calling him out in spanish ricardo had
no idea what he wanted and he didn't
want to wait and find out but before he
could speed up anymore two men appeared
in front of him there was no way out all
three men wrestled ricardo to the ground
and quickly threw him in the back of a
car inside he was tied up and gagged the
car sped off heading to a nearby safe
house now before you feel bad about our
family man ricardo that wasn't his real
identity ricardo clement was a fake name
given to a man named adolf eichmann
adolf eichmann had a nickname the
architect of the holocaust yes our
humble car salesman with a wife and kids
was really the man that was behind some
of the worst crimes committed by germany
in world war ii and now he was in the
hands of the world's most secretive
intelligence agency mossad think of
mossad as israel's version of the cia
except they're smaller more nimble more
secretive and way more ruthless
since world war ii israel has killed
more people in targeted assassinations
than any other country in the western
world
in just 70 years of its existence it's
carried out over 2 700 operations
including kidnappings torturing stealing
secrets and more
mossad has killed so many people over
the years that they even had their own
wikipedia page called lists of israeli
assassinations and on that day in 1960
mossada just successfully captured the
most wanted german in the world in the
span of 10 minutes
right after the war adolf eichmann was
captured by the us but quickly escaped
and fled to argentina five years later
reports started surfacing that he was
hiding in argentina under a false
identity after months of surveillance
and research it was confirmed ricardo
clement a nobody employee at
mercedes-benz was one of mossad's most
wanted and the orders were given to
bring him back to israel the eight-man
mossad team tailed eichmann for weeks he
had made the same mistake everyone does
when they get too comfortable he got
into a routine he would leave for work
at the same time every day come home at
the same time every day and use the
exact same bus without fail on may 11th
the mission had almost been embroidered
when he didn't show up for his usual bus
but a little patience had been all they
needed and soon they spotted their
targets
tied up and gagged eichmann was taken to
a mossad safe house where he was
interrogated for nine days to make sure
they had the right guy back in the 50s
there wasn't cctv or facial recognition
so the only way to know they have the
right guy was for him to confess which
he did the only thing left was to
extract him back to israel the eight
israeli agents dressed him up as an
israeli airline flight attendant stuck
him in first class heavily sedated him
and passed him off as a sick employee
when he arrived in israel he was quickly
put on trial which saw testimony from
more than a hundred of his victims and
witnesses
adolf eichmann was executed by hanging
in 1962. it was mossad's first major
operational success the agency had
flexed his muscles and now it was out
for blood
this is mossad the most trigger happy
spy agency in the world
[Music]
if you watch this channel you're
obviously ambitious and want the most
out of life and a big part of a good
first impression is having a full head
of healthy hair the problem is most men
start experiencing significant hair loss
by the time they reach 35. two out of
every three guys to be exact and
according to my youtube analytics a good
chunk of you are creeping up on that age
but lucky for you that's where keeps
comes in keeps is a one-of-a-kind
subscription service that gives you fda
approved hair loss treatments delivered
right to your door at half of the price
of what you would pay at a pharmacy
because they use generic versions of fda
approved hair loss medications here's
how easy keeping your hair can be you
choose the affordable plan that best
fits your hair situation a licensed
doctor will check to make sure it's
everything you need and nothing you
don't and then you set it and forget it
your keeps treatment is shipped right to
your door every three months and then
you start using your treatment while you
track your progress online and you get
constant access to your doctor through
online messaging everyone is different
but most people who use keeps typically
start seeing results in just four to six
months so it's really important to act
fast the sooner you start using keeps
the more hair you'll save hair loss
stops with keeps if you're ready to take
action and save your hair go to
keeps.comtrend or click the link below
to receive 50 off your first order
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com jake tran with
the link below thanks to keeps for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
mossad thrives off its ability to stay
in the shadows and keep its operations a
secret one of the reasons why the agency
is so revered is because people know
almost nothing about it we know it was
founded in 1950 soon after the jews
started settling in what would become
israel but we didn't even know who its
director was until 1996.
unlike other spy agencies mossad works
almost 100 in the shadows reporting only
to the prime minister of israel and
having no real laws that define what it
can or can't do now you might be
wondering how does a country so small
with a population of only around 9
million people develop one of the most
respected and sophisticated intelligence
agencies in the world
out of desperation
israel is a tiny nation surrounded by
people that absolutely want to destroy
them from all sides and when you're a
nation in a precarious situation like
this you're gonna need to turn to some
desperate measures to keep your country
safe you see with enemies all around
them the leaders of israel realized that
they were gonna need way more than just
an army to avoid being wiped off the
face of the earth to give you an idea of
the disadvantage they're at the israeli
defense force has around 170 000 active
personnel while iran their arch enemy
has over 600 thousand
so assassinations kidnappings torturings
it all becomes fair game when your life
is at stake today israel is supported by
the us who supplies them with weapons
military tech planes and billions of
dollars in military aid each year
so even though its army is so small it's
one of the strongest in the middle east
but way back in the 50s when the nation
was just finding its feet it was way
less capable and needed a way to
discover and eliminate threats quickly
and quietly
enter mossad israel's national
intelligence agency and one of three
organizations in israel's intelligence
community they shared their space with
amman israel's military intelligence and
the shin bets for internal security and
although these three agencies often
cooperate on missions no one has gained
as much infamy for their successes and
their failures as mossad
[Music]
one of the main focuses of mossad is
gathering intel on a threat much closer
to home the palestinians there have been
dozens of attacks over the years but
none as bad as the munich olympics
massacre in 1972 a group of palestinian
militants known as black september
attacked the israeli athletes and
coaches participating in the games 11
hostages were killed along with a couple
palestinians the german government set
out to investigate but it wasn't enough
for israel instead mossad created a
special hit squad under the codename
operation wrath of god
their mission find and eliminate anyone
involved in the attack directly or
indirectly over the next year or so
mossad agents assassinated almost every
last one of the palestinians in black
september they were so eager for revenge
they even killed an innocent moroccan
waiter in norway mistaking him for
another name on their kill list you'd
imagine mossad was slowed down after
killing an innocent man but they didn't
they were there to eliminate their
enemies and sometimes collateral damage
is just a part of the game so mossad
became even more infamous so much so
that an israeli journalism agency called
the jerusalem post reported on operation
wrath of god years later as a massive
success not once mentioning that mossad
has slipped up this became the status
quo for mossad's reputation in israel
they became infamous for their successes
and abilities with their mistakes and
failures quickly brushed off as hazards
of the trade
[Music]
since 2004 mossad had been tasked with
sabotaging iran's nuclear weapons
program according to israeli
intelligence iran was working on a
covert program to develop a nuclear
warhead small enough to fit on top of
their long-range missiles so since 2007
mossad had assassinated the iranian
general in charge of missile
developments 16 members of his team
along with five iranian nuclear
scientists but one man kept escaping
mossad's grasp most in fact rosade the
father of iran's nuclear program mossad
had used a number of different
techniques for the other assassinations
poison a remote bomb attached to a
motorcycle riding up next to the target
in a motorcycle then shooting through
the window or attaching a sticky bomb to
the car but the planning for those were
too complex and too risky and led to
assets getting caught and executed so
this time mossad was going to try
something new a remote controlled
machine gun hidden in the back of an
unsuspecting pickup truck you heard that
right something like this had never been
tried by long before but due to
circumstances the plan was both approved
by israel and the us first they had to
figure out how to get the weapon in
place the weapon of choice was a
modified version of the fn mag machine
gun attached to a robot armor cameras
kind of like this off-the-rack sentinel
20 robot machine gun but altogether the
system weighed around a ton so it had to
be broken down and smuggled into iran in
parts the weapon was reassembled onto a
common pickup truck model in iran and
the robot was equipped with facial
recognition and software to account for
both the gun's recoil and the 1.6 second
delay in the video feed and the truck
was rigged with explosives to detonate
after the job was done to destroy
evidence and then the game was on friday
november 27 2020 thakurazade starts his
commute with his wife in the car
escorted by an armored convoy his car
however was not armored he had received
a warning of a potential assassination
attempt on him that day and he chose to
ignore it the pickup truck with the
remote controlled machine gun was placed
along their routes right in front of a
speed bump
once the convoy got into the kill zone
the remote control machine gun fired in
at least three bursts and in under 60
seconds the father of iran's nuclear
program was assassinated and the truck
exploded
unfortunately the explosives didn't
successfully destroy the weapon system
and the iranians got a hold of the
evidence if it wasn't for that hiccup
the world might have never known just
how advanced mossad had gone with their
wet work
[Music]
thank you so much
although mossad is supposed to be an
intelligence agency at hearts over the
years it has become just as much an
execution agency and they've become
masters at their craft now whenever a
name comes up for elimination agents
know exactly what to do take it to the
prime minister once he and his top
ministers decide the target is worth
going after the kill order is issued and
then it's time to arrange a meeting
between the target and god
whether is using fake passports and
assassinating members of hamas palace
has resistant movement in places like
dubai or tunisia or going after iranian
nuclear scientists in the name of
protecting israel mossad agents are
experts at killing people and
disappearing soon after and every time
war gets out about another successful
hits more and more israeli citizens
rushed to join the agency
this fact the outright support of
israelis from assad's assassinations is
one of the biggest factors that sets the
agency apart from all others
unlike agencies like the cia or mi6
israeli spice don't have the luxury of
printing new passports whenever they
have to head out on a new mission
american and british passports are
strong and accepted in most countries
while israelis are suspected pretty much
everywhere they go their solution use
the passports of real israeli dual
citizens from all over the world that's
how mossad teams could get into dubai
and other unfriendly territories without
being noticed they find a willing
israeli who has dual citizenship and a
passport from somewhere like germany or
america they borrow their passport
complete the mission and quietly return
the passport to its original owner and
it's not like this is by force either
israelis willingly volunteer their
passports on a regular basis and that's
not all across the world every jewish or
israeli man woman student or general
worker can become what they call a
saiyan a helper probably not pronouncing
that right sayenim or unpaid assets of
the mossad that are used to pass
messages transport weapons or make life
easier for mossad agents all over the
world just in america there's an
estimated 16 thousand of the saiyan nyms
waiting on the silence whenever a mossad
agent needs help this could be renting
on a car letting them use their property
for a while or even just being a witness
or alibi to get mossad agents out of
trouble
is this sort of patriotism and
willingness to put their lives on the
line for their countrymen that allow
mossad one of the smallest intelligence
agencies in the world to become one of
the most feared in the world
you know who else was jewish everyone's
favorite private island owner every
jeff's team i have jewish friends that i
love don't get all offended please we
have an exclusive documentary coming out
soon on afrojeffstein that will only be
available to members of this channel and
you can join right now by clicking the
join button below or the link below if
you don't see the join button you'll get
access to the past private documentaries
that our members have been raving about
and this one when it comes out in the
next few weeks i put out new private
documentaries every month on things that
are too controversial to post publicly
that they will never teach you in
business school and if you join and
don't think it's worth it email me and i
will personally give you a refund click
that join button below to join now
you